[تصفيق]
امريكا
2020 فاجات رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
الجامعه بتمزيق خطاب قدمه الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب لاعضاء الكونغرس كانت تلك
اللقطه جزءا من مواقفه مثيره للجدل عرفت
بها فيلوسي وبما انها الثانيه في الترتيب
بينما قد يتولون الرئاسه بعد الرئيس فهو
لم يكن مجرد اعتراض اعتبر تسديدا لما
تعيشه الولايات المتحده من حاله استقبال
منذ عام
1987 شغلت بيلوسي مقعدا في مجلس النواب
كنائبه عن الحزب الديمقراطي حتى جاء عام
2007 ومعه اصبحت نانسي بيلوسي اولا امراه
تراس مجلس النواب الامريكي من بين قائمه
تضم 53 رجل مجلس منذ تاسيسه قبل قرنين
عندما فقد الحزب الديمقراطي اغلبيه المجلس
عام 2011 غادرت بلوس مقعد الرئاسه الى
مقعدها الاعتيادي عن الدائره الثانيه عشر
بولايه كاليفورنيا
لم يتوقع احد عودتها الى رئاسه المجلس
لكنها فاجات الكثيرين عام 2019 بترشحها
لرئاسه المجلس وتقلدها مره اخرى لدورتين
متتاليتين تنتهيان بحلول عام
بذلك اصبحت فلوس واحده من سبعه سياسيين
امريكيين غدروا رئاسه مجلس النواب ثم
عادوا اليها لاحقا
لم تتوقف عن مناكفه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق العزل
[موسيقى]
كعادتها في صناعه المفاجاه ظهرت
عسكريه مع جارتها الصين بيلوسي واثاره غضب
السلطات الصينيه موقفا ثابت ففي
1989 ظهرت ميدانات
فيه المتظاهرون ضد السلطات الصينيه
[موسيقى]